[Music]  [Applause]   [Music] [Applause]  sinter and wake up bracket servant girl  is what you are is what you will always  be no one in the kingdom will outshine  my daughters who's this for  it was my mother's address but you shall  not go to the ball excuse me  why are you crying oh you let me slip  into something more comfortable  applause and you find that really  comfortable now a fever or you shall go  to the ball  yeah where there is kindness there is  goodness but where there is goodness  there is magic they're all looking you  here  believe me they're all looking at me  come with me  remember of the NA spell at the house  track at midnight  [Music]  I have to see her again  [Music]